الى روسيا حيث طلب رئيس روسي فلاديمير
بوتين من العقيده المتقاعد اوندرين نيكولي
الذي كان احد ابرز قاده فاجنر العسكريين
الاشراف على تشكيل وحدات تطوعيه يمكنها
اداء مهام قتاليه مختلفه خصوصا في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه جاء ذلك خلال
لقاء حضره ايضا نائب وزير الدفاع
اود ان ابدا اجتماعنا بالحديث معكم في
اجتماعنا الاخير تحدثنا عن تشكيلكم وحدات
تطوعيه يمكنها اداء مهام قتاليه مختلفه
خصوصا في منطقه العمليات العسكريه الخاصه
انت قاتلت في مثل هذه الوحدات لاكثر من
عام وانت على درايه بهذا الامر وكيف يبدا
وتعرفون القضايا التي يجب حلها مسبقا حتى
يستمر العمل القتالي بافضل وانجح طريقه
ومن جانبها قالت الاستخبارات العسكريه
البريطانيه ان من المحتمل ان مئات من
افراد ميليشيا فاجنر بداوا اعاده الانتشار
في اوكرانيا واضافت في منشور لها على منصه
اكس ان العمليه انجزت على مستوى الافراد
والمجموعات الصغيره التي تقاتل ضمن
الوحدات المواليه لروسيا في اوكرانيا على
حديث ابيها
في باديه الامر تحياتي لكم وتحياتي
للجمهور بالطبع بوتين يريد ان يقوم
بالسيطره على وحده فاغنر ويواصل السيطره
عليها لانها تعتبر واحده من الوحدات
الاكثر فعاليه ونجاعه في هذه الحرب يتضمن
الكثير من المقاتلين الذين هم من المجرمين
السابقين وهم
ابانوا على فاعليه كبيره جدا في الميدان
اذا بوتين يريد ان يبقي السيطره في
الميدان لذلك فهو لديه هذه الوحدات التي
تتضمن كما قلنا مجرمين حتى يقوم
بالانتقام من بيجورجين لماذا لانه بعد
قتل
فان عمليه الانتقام قد بدات وهذا يوضح انه
حتى في غيابي فان العملات بامكانها ان
تبقى مستمره واعاده الانتشار من خلال هذه
الاعاده لاعاده انتشار عناصر باجنر في
مواقع القتال في اوكرانيا لها علاقه
بحسابات كما ذكرتها الان بين السيد بوتين
وقائدها السابق بروجن ام لها علاقه بما
يجري من تطورات على الارض في اوكرانيا
نعم بالطبع كما نرى فان القوات الروسيه
تواصل مواجهه خسار خسائر كبيره وبالتالي
فان الطريقه الافضل لتجنب وتجاوز هذه
المشكله هي من خلال اعاده انتشار مقاتل
فاجنر لان هؤلاء الاشخاص سيقاتلون بجانبه
ويريدوك كذلك ان يرسي اموره بشكل جيد قبل
الانتخابات لابد ان نعرف ان هذا الامر
ربما قد يؤثر على
امكانيه الحصول على اصوات في الانتخابات
لذلك هو يحاول ان يعتمد على هذه المجموعات
وذلك هناك الكثير من الاشخاص الذين يرفضون
الانضمام الى الجيش لانهم يعلمون ربما انه
قد يتم قتلهم في الميدان اذا ما ذهبوا
للمقاتله في اوكرانيا وعن نفس الموضوع
اسالك سيده اعاده انتشار قوات فاجنر في
اوكرانيا تعيين العقيده المتقاعد
ماء دلاله كل ذلك
سيد اندريه من موسكو سالتك عن دلاله اعاده
انتشار قوات فاجنر في اوكرانيا وتعيين
العقيد المتقاعد تروشيف وما دوافع موسكو
واهدافها من وراء ذلك
نعم
هل سمعت السؤال
ممكن ان سالتك عن دلالات اعاده انتشار
قوات افاجنر في اوكرانيا وتعيين العقيد
المتقاعد تروشيف ما اهداف موسكو من وراء
ذلك وفي هذا التوقيت
انا طبعا بعد محاوله التمرد وكذلك بعد
تحطم طائره
السابق كان هناك كثير من التساؤلات كيف
يجب ان تتم اعاده النظر على عناصر فاجنر
على دور فاقنر كيف يمكن ترتيب الامور على
ما يبدو تم اختيار هذا الشخص عن طريق بسبب
انه على كل حال احد زعماء البارزين لقوات
فاجنر على ما يبدو اولا هناك اهداف كثيره
حول التعايين هذا شخص واخداعه لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يعني اولا كذلك شخص الذي
كان في صفوف كان قائدا في صفوف واقدر يجب
ان يدفع العناصر البسيطين لينضموا الى
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى هذه
مجموعات المتطوعين
الجديده فكذلك
من وجهه نظره السياسي من جديد اقول
يتم اخداع قوات لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه على
ما يبدو ستكون هناك مجموعات بشكل او باخر
منفصل
من وزاره الدفاع ولكن
تعمل تحت غطاء وزاره الدفاع لتنفيذ بعض
المهام الحساسه في مختلف الاماكن العالم
ليس فقط في اوكرانيا
الامريكي يقول بان القوات الاوكرانيه
استطاعت ان تستعيد اكثر من 50% من الاراضي
التي خسرتها ببدايه الحرب هل هذا يفسر
العوده للاستعانه بعناصر فاجنر مره اخرى
من خلال ولو سياق مختلفه
يقول يعني
بعد التحكم طائره بريغورن قد باقوا كثير
من العناصر
[موسيقى]
مطروحه من قياده روسيه هي كانت مساله
كيفيه انضمام او دم هؤلاء الاشخاص الى
صفوف الجيش تم اختيار اندرويد
كقائد
السابق هذه الشخصيه يجب ان كما ذكرت فيها
سابقه يجب ان تدفع عناصر فاقنر لينضموا
الى صفوف الجيش بعيدا عن تطورات الاهداف
طبعا
عفوا هناك انقطاع في الاتصال
طيب اتحول الى الان الى سيد مكسيم من
اكياف المعارك على الارض ما تزال مشتعله
بين هجمات وهجمات مضاده الان اعاده انتشار
مقاتلي فاجنر في اوكرانيا مع قياده جديده
ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه للجيش الاوكراني
وبالنسبه للمعارك المستمره
في حقيقه الامر هذا يعني ان الان بوتين قد
قام الشخص بامكانه ان يسيطر على الوضع
وذلك تحت قياده
وهذا يوضح مدى فعاليه هذه المجموعه مقارنه
بالقوات النظاميه الروسيه اذا بوتين يريد
ان يستعين بهذه الوحدات القتاليه وهناك
اخبار تاتينا من جهات مختلفه سواء من
الجنوب او من المنطقه الشرقيه التي تقول
ان وحدات فاجنر تم نشرها في عدد من
المناطق وكذلك لوقف عمليات المضاده في
اوكرانيا وربما ذلك يرمي
لاستعداد العمليات القتاليه والهجوميه كما
هو الشان في الحمله الشتائيه او شتويه
التي جرت في
والتي شاركت فيها قوات فاجنر اذا الان كما
هو الشان دائما في روسيا الاشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم ولاء تم اقصائهم
تم استبداله بشخصيه ذات ولاء عالي وذلك
تحت مظله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه حيث ان هذا
الهدف الذي كان هو هدف الاساسي بالنسبه
لوزير الدفاع الروسي كان دائما يود ان تتم
هذه العمليات شكرا تحت وزاره الدفاع
اشكرك جزيل الشكر ماكسيم يلي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في الجامعه الوطنيه من
كييف واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من موسكو المحلل
السياسي والامني اندري